i'm here with the very sparkly rock
matthew yeah hello that's right and it's
time for jews news and today's edition
of halloween headlines
well this year it feels like nature is
inventing new animals to scare us
first the mortar hornet now a two-headed
snake
no 2020 doing us dirty a two-headed
state
this is a real thing okay check this out
livescience.com says that one family in
florida
discovered their house cat dropped off a
two-headed snake onto their living room
floor
nope oh god no i didn't know there was a
picture of it look at that oh yeah
snake nope two-headed snake nope
two-headed snake in my home please gosh
stop
that's not for me well i looked at it up
close and i thought maybe
it just got split and that's what
happened but apparently it is a
two-headed snake
i mean you know i want to love all of
our creatures so i kind of like i want
to be nice to it just like karmically
but it's freaky well maybe we have a new
mascot for 2020.
okay ross what's special about this
particular halloween stream well did you
know that saturday is not only a
halloween but it's also a
fool a full moon and it's only happened
twice since 1955 back in 1974 and 2001.
so drew because it is a full moon on
halloween
should we howl i was hoping you would i
would
love to help ready count us
[Applause]
this is the weirdest show on tv i love
that
i love it too it makes me so happy
okay and by the way when you fall asleep
saturday don't forget
don't be surprised because you have to
set your clocks back right it's daylight
savings time and i always forget it
i know i actually always forget it on
purpose
but it's happening this weekend news you
can use
news you can use yeah and by the way
your phones now in 2020 actually do it
for you
just let your phone do the work okay
well this might scare everyone
check out this freaky food foot
voraciously calls it feet loaf
it's regular meatloaf shaped into the
form of a severed foot
just add ketchup
come on are you down with feet loaf
i'll tell you that is quite a feat um
and you know it actually pairs nicely
with a little toe jam
people you have too much time on your
hands in 2020 you're making feet loaf
i mean there are many body parts i
suppose we could make with
uh meatloaf let's stop at the feet shall
we
well those are my halloween headlines
but i heard you brought some spooky fun
facts
about the holiday take it away ron i did
i know you love halloween so it's time
for fun facts halloween edition
fun all right just a little spooky bits
of trivia about your favorite holiday
did you know this drew mm-hmm i bet you
do you sample your
kids candy uh when they go
trick-or-treating i sample my kids
everything especially the macaroni and
cheese well you are we are not alone
when it comes to halloween candy because
72 percent of parents admit that they
secretly eat their children's candy
we're all guilty of eating our kids food
no i i walk by a snickers i gain five
pounds no it's not happening i know
fun fact number two remember when the
exorcist came out
scary scary movie uh people were freaked
out and
the movie theaters actually handed out
to moviegoers
barf bags that's a true story halloween
yes that's a fun fact
that is such an amazing fact i love that
what movie has
done that since yeah i don't think they
put it in the ads you know
come come come to the movies and hurl no
okay oh fun fact number three do you
know how much people spend
on their halloween pet costumes every
year
okay look at that i think we might be
guilty of that worth every single penny
all
370 million dollars a year
on halloween pet costumes yeah you know
because
people's pets are like their children
they're a family member even if you have
kids you know i mean they people invest
in their pets so i'm weirdly not
surprised by that one
i have three dogs and i'll tell you uh
you're welcome because i've contributed
to that 370 million
yeah well ross i love these fun facts
they're light they're fluffy and
[Music]
delicious